do you feel like it's a thing because
girls like bat out of their league so to
speak
are you asking me yeah that's from like
a guy's point
i've heard that theory before you know i
don't i don't i think it's that because
i don't believe in out of your league
when you say out of your league what do
you mean by really you don't you don't
believe in people have leagues but no
but i want you to define what you mean
because there's different there's
different ways i could take it okay so
like you rate someone one to ten so
we've got enough looks yeah looks
see because it starts with blocks
so you're saying
but that wouldn't explain why they would
lie to you to get what you want because
hypothetically speaking if i'm a 10 and
you're a two i'm going to get what i
want easier i don't even have to really
lie i could just be like give me what i
want you should be happy to be around me
so you wouldn't really need to lie for
that so i don't think it comes from that
if that's a if that's the thought
process i think it just comes from a
thing of people are selfish now so
there's less of an urge for men to
protect women like they would have been
before that men used to like if you go
back generations and generations your
grandparents there was more of a thing
chivalrous look after women take care of
them protect them and so on and so forth
as time has passed now men are just like
i want what i want and that's it i don't
that's not my experience like i think
most guys
like there's a lot of guys willing to do
that it's just that girls don't want
them
you know women women rate the majority
of men is unattractive i think it's like
80 90 percent of men women rate
unattractive
definitely i think women i often say
women overlook some good men you are
ignoring the bin man the pulse man some
regular guys you don't want the flag
guys but the flag guy's got a lot of
options so you're just another one but
the bin men and postman
more appreciative hard-working getting
on with their day-to-day trainer you
know and you don't want him known but
that's what i mean when i say like girls
are batting out of their league because
they're going for the guy that every
girl wants
and so
like of course like that's going to
happen when you go for the guy that
everyone wants
because he'll sleep with a bunch of
girls but like who's he going to commit
to yes so maybe it's not that there's no
maybe it's not out of their league it's
just the wrong choice because she could
be a 10 he could be attempted but his
mentality is wrong because he's he his
mentality is that i've got all of you so
why do i need you so it's not
necessarily at the league it's just
a mentality thing like i guess
i wouldn't know because i've always been
a good guy
yeah yeah you've never ghosted a girl
not good
i was never ghosted i never goes through
that well you know ghost is a struggle
word though you think i'm good and i
just jump out like boo i'm here so i'd
be honest and up front and just be like
listen it's not working out i'm pretty
much a straight talker